a woman from Northern Ireland denied
access to her late partner's pension
because they were not married has been
told she is entitled to the payments at
Denise Bruce's partner Lenny McMullen
died suddenly in 2009 just two days
after the couple were engaged
she'd been denied payments from his
pension because they didn't fill in an
extra form required for unmarried
couples but today the Supreme Court
ruled that this was discriminatory and
that miss Brewster should receive the
payments we were joined by harini a
Yangon barrister who specializes in
discrimination and employment law at
eleven KBW law firm Harun II thank you
very much for being with us and what is
the significance of this particular
ruling I mean from whence does this
supreme court decide that what has
happened in the past
thousands of unmarried people not
getting access to pensions may well be
turned on its head well miss Brewster's
been kept out of her partner's pension
since he died about eight years ago it's
going to have big implications for
people in the same situation here in
Northern Ireland the law was changed in
England and Wales around 2014 and then
from a wider legal perspective it's got
implications about this type of
government scheme which makes provision
for suffer I mean for pensions or other
kind of benefits and I think those
operating those schemes now we'll be
looking at this decision and asking
themselves you know other parts of our
scheme that treat unmarried couples
differently from married couples or
civil partners I mean it's something
that you would have assumed that firms
and public institutions would have
considered a lot more carefully given
just how many of us are living in in
relationships of this type these days
absolutely I think the case says that
one in six couples are unmarried couples
living together so not married not in a
civil partnership and actually the
regulations that were the whole focus of
this judgment in the Supreme Court were
put into force with the aim of making
things equal for cohabiting couples and
married and civil partners and it was
just this requirement that there should
be a nomination form sent in that led to
miss Brewster not getting her survivors
pension and this was based around
article 14 of the ECHR one wonders
whether or not
given that there are some movements in
terms of a relationship with at the
European Court of Justice with the
European Union
this will continue yeah I thought it's
very interesting so under Article
fourteen there are various kinds of
discrimination there too outlawed and
marital status so being a cohabit ear a
thurr than a wife or a civil partner is
what this distinction was based on and
that's outlawed under Article fourteen
discrimination on the basis of marital
status and you're quite right if we were
ever to leave the European Convention on
Human Rights you wouldn't be able to
succeed in this type of case but
actually we just don't know what's going
to happen in regard to that I've I've
seen today just on the way here actually
that the Minister for brexit has
responded to a written question that was
about article three to do with
prohibition on torture and he said in
response to that that the government has
no plans to leave the European
Convention on Human Rights but I don't
think anyone's asked the government
specifically about article fourteen or
about article one protocol one which is
the right to enjoy your possessions
peacefully which was also in play here
because mr. McMullin had been paying
into his pension scheme for 15 years and
he'd been living with MS Brewster for
ten years and it was their right to his
property in his pension that was in
question her any I rather suspect given
the outcome of the case at the Supreme
Court people will now be asking the
government exactly those questions but
given the distress given that the
financial concerns of of taking a case
like this all the way to the Supreme
Court what is the situation now for
couples in this position or for someone
who's been bereaved but has been
cohabiting in Northern Ireland do they
then have to take this case all the way
to the Supreme Court to ensure that they
get what they ought from the pension no
I mean I imagine what would happen is
that maybe they haven't yet had a
decision and I think those making the
decisions in Northern Ireland now will
be obviously looking at this judgment
and making their decision in the light
of the guidance from the Supreme Court
if people have had a decision then they
need to take advice about how to go back
to the decision-maker and say look have
you seen the decision of the Supreme
Court and can I please ask you to look
again at it
we'll keep our fingers crossed certainly
a judgment that plenty of people are
discussing today our only agenda thanks
very much for being with us and scaring
hee